professor terence tau is the equivalent
of a rock star in mathematics
regarded as the greatest mathematician
alive
as long as i can remember i have always
loved numbers and puzzles and patterns
sometimes because of the way it's taught
an innate mathematical ability it
doesn't feel connected to the way we
learn math but i think we all have an
innate ability for mathematics
[Music]
knowing how to think mathematically can
be a tool that you can use to solve
problems in a systematic way i like to
think that this class is for anyone
really in fact maybe this class is even
more suitable for people who have not
had formal mathematical training i'm not
going to give you homework the way i
approached problems in mathematics it
was to try to turn it into a game
a large part of this class will be about
talking about problem solving we
abstract them we break them up into
pieces we make analogies we try to find
connections with other problems
the first player who can collect three
numbers that add up to 15 wins the game
playing this game is quite challenging
if you don't know the trick you can
transform this to a much more familiar
game tic-tac-toe people often
anthromorphize mathematical objects they
call this guy the enemy this guy is your
friend
some people call them slightly more
obscene names okay
in this class you'll appreciate a little
bit more what mathematics is how we
solve problems and how some of these
strategies can be of use to you in your
daily life the ideal problem to work on
is one which is just barely outside of
your reach
it's not so much whether you succeed or
fail a question but it's whether you can
learn something from it
my name is terence tao and this is
masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]